transheiser bush is in hot water
transheiser Bush just had the worst
thing happen to it that could possibly
happen to it you know that the sales for
Bud Light have been declining
dramatically and that's true of even
other a b inbev
beverages Bud heavy and other beers now
it's started to level off for the other
companies
they're still declining in sales but the
rate at which they're declining has
leveled off for Bud Light though it's
just a precipitous drop and now on top
of that
transheiser bush has just lost its
perfect score from the Human Rights
Campaign that's a pro LGBT organization
from their corporate equality index and
why did they lose their perfect score
because transheiser Bush tried to stand
in the middle of the road they're going
to get hit by a truck and they just did
get hit by a truck they tried to have it
both ways
so they irritated the customer base
which has now abandoned it and
they've irritated the the Gestapo over
there at the Human Rights Campaign and
it's not just this one group it's the
institutional investors it's the major
asset managers like BlackRock State
Street and Vanguard
it's garm it's the industry-wide
Coalition that says that we are going to
support transgenderism and we're going
to suppress speech that opposes
transgenderism
and so now because they didn't defend
Dylan Mulvaney hard enough
they've lost their perfect score which
is going to hurt them among investors
it's going to hurt them in the eyes of
the small group of radical liberal
Elites who are going to wield corporate
power to install their unpopular and
absurd ideologies the transgender stuff
is obviously not coming from the people
this is not a Grassroots movement the
vast majority of Americans think
transgenderism is totally bunk and an
even greater vast majority of Americans
don't want the ideology anywhere near
their kids so this is not just power to
the people we're finally going to have
our rights to chop our genitals off this
is coming from a radical small group of
Elites and so it's ironic that the
Associated Press right now which is a
very far left increasingly far left news
organization has come out and said that
it's actually the anti-trans activism
that is coming from a small group of
Elites the AP says with more than a
dozen states and acting laws limiting
gender affirming care means
gender denying care for transgender
minors namely confused kids who are
being abused by the adults around them
and AP analysis found that many of those
bills stemmed not from a Grassroots
movement but from a handful of
conservative interest groups model
legislation and to that I say
yeah sure probably
there there is more of a Grassroots
movement against transgenderism
obviously there is for transgenderism
because parents are seeing their kids
being taught this stuff and are in a
fairly organic way showing up to school
board meetings to protest it but yeah
both of these things are true
there are committed groups with clear
political Visions who are running
political campaigns for and against
transgenderism that's not a big shock
that's not a huge conspiracy
that is true of every political movement
every political movement is Advanced by
a small and determined group of people
most people just have other things to do
and they don't pay very close attention
to politics they don't spend all of
their life printing out Palm cards and
campaigning and knocking on doors and
showing up to public meetings it's
always whether we're talking about the
Bolsheviks whether we're talking about
the Tea Party whether we're talking
about any political movement ever
it's a small group of people which is
why conservatives need to expand their
imagination okay because conservatives
we sometimes think well how are we going
to convince the median Vote or the
Suburban moms the libs never think about
that the libs never think how are we
kind of convinced American women that
their babies aren't really babies and we
should be able to murder them the libs
never think well how are we oh goodness
don't we might lose the suburbs the
Suburban moms if we if we try to trans
their kindergartners in the public
school they never they just they just go
for it they have a broad political
imagination in fact that's one of their
their slogans they say some people see
things that are and say why I dream
things that ever were and say why not
it's line from JFK his brother RFK used
it Democrats have used it for many many
years comes from a socialist playwright
actually comes from the mouth of the
devil in the Socialist playwrights play
about the Garden of Eden ties right in
with all the rest of the liberal
political vision
and that's what they do why don't
conservatives do that too it's a small
determined band of people that persuade
the public yeah I guess you're probably
right all right let's get more
determined let's get even clearer let's
keep pushing right now go to
puretalk.com Knowles do you remember the
last time you got a free phone started
out feeling great and then came the
Hefty activation fees the four-line
requirements and of course that binding
contract Pure Talk is giving you a free
5G Samsung Galaxy phone without the
feeling that you've been duped when you
switch to Pure talks unlimited talk and
text data plan that comes with a mobile
hotspot you will get a 5G Samsung Galaxy
for free that's right unlimited
everything at a fraction of the price of
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile here's the thing
you'll be on America's Most Dependable
5G network not just a similar network
but the very same one how do I know
because I'm a customer make the switch
to Pure Talk the cell phone Wireless
company I am proud to stand behind
because they provide a phenomenal
product and they're proud to stand
behind our mission at the daily wire
pure talks us-based customer service
team helps make the switch in as little
as 10 minutes and you can even keep your
phone number go to puretalk.com Knowles
kwles for your free Samsung Galaxy when
you sign up for unlimited talk text and
unlimited data that is puretalk.com
Knowles Pure Talk Wireless for Americans
by Americans as we approach pride month
something tells me there's going to be
more LGBT stuff in the news there is a
Nebraska state senator her name is
Senator Michaela Kavanaugh
she has made I think one of the
relatively most articulate arguments in
support of the transgender ideology and
policies that affirm this ideology that
I have ever heard Senator Kavanaugh take
it away
these people we love trans people trans
people belong here we need trans people
we love trans people trans people
belongs we need trans people we love
trans people trans people belong here we
need trans people
I haven't considered that
from America
interesting perspective
she goes on for another like two or
three minutes but I I think I've got the
broad Strokes of the argument my
favorite part of the clip is that no one
joined in she was obviously trying to
start a chant for everybody like it's
like a guy who gets him in a baseball
game here we go Yankees here we go
here we go Yankees why are they joining
again here we go here we go okay all
right maybe I'll just sit down then so
no but nobody joined in to the champ
why did this lady recite these mantras
over and over again rather than making
an argument rather than presenting
evidence why did she just chant
why did she do that because
the left-wing political agenda and
especially the transgender agenda
is less a matter of rational argument
and much more a matter of of a cult
ecstasy
spiritual ecstasy
it's not just the trans agenda though
it's the climate activism it's all the
rest of it we need to save the planet
how dare you now you know they just they
just sort of yell
scream
and they don't make calm clear arguments
what is her thesis in this mantra
we need trans people
my first reaction to that was
do we
are we one is there any such thing as
trans people I don't think so because
the premise of transgenderism is that
you can be the opposite sex secretly but
but but have the physical appearance of
the other sex and that isn't true
so we don't is do we have a shortage of
trans people there aren't enough trans
people we need to make more trans people
we need to encourage more people to to
become trans well actually that's what
the conservatives are accusing the libs
of doing and the libs are saying we're
not doing that we're not grooming
anybody we're not encouraging people to
do this but obviously they are and this
woman is admitting that implicitly with
her Mantra we need what
even if trans people existed as a real
ontological category which they don't
but let's say they did
what would we need them uniquely to do
is there something vacant can they fly
can they
read minds can they what special gift
does this group of people have that
other people don't have
this is the same kind of argument that
the libs make this is a more Fantastical
version of it obviously but it's the
same kind of argument that the libs make
and they say we need millions of illegal
aliens from Venezuela to come across
every year because without them who will
pick our grapes
as though Venezuelans have this unique
ability to pick grapes and no other
group of people in the face of the Earth
can pick grapes or what the libs say
they don't even realize how
condescending this is they'll say we
need all these Venezuelans to come
across to America because we need them
to clean our toilets do you think how
offensive is that Venezuelans and
everybody else it's offensive to
everybody
to say this group of people
they are preternaturally gifted at
scrubbing toilets
and also every other person on Earth
black white asian other kinds of
Hispanic who don't come over in words
those people they're just not able to do
it they get a scrub brush they just
think oh what do I do with this they put
rub it on the ceiling there where does
this thing go
you know we don't need you could make an
argument that we want to take more
Hispanic migrants across the Rio Grande
we want to do that because of X Y and Z
or we want you could make the argument
we want people to engage in sexually
deviant behaviors or sexually
destructive behaviors you can make that
argument probably wouldn't be very
persuasive
say we need
to enshrine this false and destructive
ideology in our public life I don't
just don't really see it man what a
great clip that was make sure you ring
the bell and subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time